sur ces images prises par une caméra de
vidéosurveillance à 18h28 un jeune homme
se fait agresser par une dizaine de
personnes
il s'appelle youri il est collégien et
il a alors 14 ans quelques minutes après
cette scène
youri et conduit par les pompiers à
l'hôpital moins de trois heures après
les faits une témoin poste ce tweet je
suis traumatisé j'ai vu un gars de 15
ans par terre avec le crâne en sang sur
la dalle de beaugrenelle il a été
tabassé par des mecs avec une béquille
une enquête pour tentative d'homicide
volontaire en réunion est ouverte ce
jour là
il n'arrêtait pas de crier je veux pas
mourir je veux pas mourir et c'est dans
cet état que sa mère elle l'a vu quand
les pompiers il était en train de
l'embarquer dans un camion pompier
et puis arrivée à l'hôpital les médecins
tout de suite ils ont plongé dans le
coma parce que vu des blessures qui
l'avaient c'était c'était la seule
solution en fait le 18 janvier à 20h25
la cousine de la mer de youri fait un
appel à témoins sur twitter retweeter
plus de neuf mille fois vendredi 15
janvier dans l'après midi un groupe
d'environ dix personnes s'est acharné
sur un adolescent de 14 ans youri mon
neveu du riz à l'hôpital entre la vie et
la mort je fais appel aux témoins pour
retrouver les coupables
justice pour youri les gens ils ont
compris ce qui s'était passé
ils ont commencé à partager partager
partager un maximum et tout ça est du
coup le compte
natalia a créé maman de youri qui a
monté en une semaine plus de cent mille
abonnés on a aussi réussi grâce à ça a
touché et attirer l'attention des médias
et tout le 20 janvier à 15h07 le site
actus.fr parle de l'agression et donne
le premier témoignage de natalia croûte
chez nick la mère de youri je me suis
inquiété parce qu'il ne répondait pas au
téléphone alors qu'il aurait dû être
rentré quand je les ai vus dans le
camion de pompier il avait le crâne
ouvert à plusieurs endroits
c'était vraiment horrible il m'a dit
qu'il ne connaissait pas les individus
qui l'avaient mal qu'il avait froid et
qu'il ne voulait pas mourir
le 21 janvier l'appel de natalia croûte
chez nick est repris dans plusieurs
médias
ce jour là c'est l'anniversaire des 15
ans de hewitt no 22 janvier aux
alentours de 17 heures les images d'une
caméra de vidéosurveillance fuites sur
les réseaux sociaux la vidéo est
partagée sur ce compte twitter est fait
à partir de là que nous avons pris la
mesure de cette affaire le 23 janvier
plusieurs dirigeants politiques
réagissent à la vidéo comme gérald
darmanin une attaque d'une sauvagerie
inouïe soutien au jeune garçon et à sa
famille l' enquête doit permettre de
faire toute la lumière sur les faits et
d'interpeller les auteurs de cet acte
immonde nous marine le pen
doit-on s'habituer à 7 ans sauvagement
doit-on s'habituer à ces lynchages
barbare
aujourd'hui youri demain qui le
gouvernement ne peut plus fermer les
yeux sur cette ultra violence du
quotidien et me répondre que par la
culture de l'excusé insoutenable j'ai
hésité mais je les diffuser parce que
trop c'est trop
ce jour là la mère de youri est
interviewé sur les chaînes d'info
continue et encore mieux
il commence à se réveiller mais
il n'est pas encore complètement avec
nous et ils essayent de nous parler mais
il n'arrive pas pour enfin plusieurs
personnalités réagissent également comme
os marsillon bon rétablissement à toi
youri je pense bien à toi et aux tiens
antoine griezmann
des images insoutenables force à toi
youri et bon rétablissement à l'étranger
aussi les images sont partagés notamment
par l'ancien footballeur espagnol iker
casillas
quel est ce [__] de monde qu'est ce
qui ne va pas chez nous le 24 janvier à
14h09 le compte twitter anonyme rétablir
la vérité qui vient juste d'être créée
partage cette vidéo qui n'est pour
l'instant pas identifié le tweet précise
c'est bien beau de parler sans connaître
toute l'histoire personne ne cautionne
ce qui est arrivé à youri mais le petit
garçon qui s'est fait tabasser à 100
juste avant par la bande de youri
pourquoi personne n'en parle
est ce à cause de sa couleur de peau ce
lundi 25 janvier yu wei est toujours à
l'hôpital